[Musik]
mit 1 wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend vielleicht hatte annegret
kramp karrenbauer ist schon geahnt als
sie vor knapp elf monaten
zur neuen cdu chefin gewählt wurde das
ergebnis war knapp
und der unterlegene friedrich merz und
seine mannen sah nicht glücklich aus
prompt erscheint märz jetzt als
wiedergänger und haut auf den putz aber
so richtig aus seiner sicht ist die
gelegenheit günstig eine reihe wahl mit
verlusten zuletzt am wochenende dass
thüringen debakel
zwar kritisiert märz ausdrücklich nur
kanzlerin merkel aber kramp karrenbauer
darf sich da getrost mit gemeint fühlen
weniger berichtet es gibt feinde
erzfeinde und als steigerung gibt es
angela merkel und friedrich merz
sie sind sich in abneigung verbunden
spätestens seit diesem herbst vor 17
jahren als märz für merkel platz machen
musste er verlor den fraktionsvorsitz
halte kräftig gegen sie aus sie habe
gegen ihn intrigiert sich nicht an
verabredungen gehalten
wir sind uns darüber einig friedrich
merz hat mir das übrigens gestern auch
bereits am telefon gesagt dass weitere
interviews dieser art nicht folgen
werden einig waren die beiden seitdem
nie wieder
merkel wurde kanzlerin als kanzler
alternative lässt mehrt sich seit
vergangenem herbst von der basis feiern
eindruck macht auf manche dass merz
merkel so angeht wie im zdf gestern
märz merkels chefkritiker wir sind in
einer ganz schwierigen situation
das hängt nach meinem eindruck aber vor
allem damit zusammen dass sich seit
jahren über dieses land wie eine wie ein
wie ein nebel teppich die die
untätigkeit und die mangelnde führung
durch die bundeskanzlerin legt das ist
der hauptkritikpunkt den ich wahrnehme
märz zur seite springen vor allem
altgediente angeblich unabgesprochen
roland koch zb morgen in einem aufsatz
er unterstellt der cdu-führung und
merkel eine argumentation cent haltung
deutschland brauche eine kanzlerin die
durch das land reise und für ihre
konzepte und auch ihre kompromisse werbe
ihr baldiges ausscheiden sei keine
hinreichende erklärung angela merkel
selbst schweigt nicht mal ignorieren so
verfährt sie schon lange mit dieser art
von kritik ihre verteidigung übernehmen
andere
ich halte das nicht für hilfreich gerade
wenn das von der seitenlinie kommt von
menschen die mal verantwortung für die
union getragen haben aber das ist auch
lange vorbei
und immer dann wenn sozusagen möglich
ist meine schlagzeile zu produzieren
dann sieht man was von ihnen und wenn es
darum geht dann wirklich auch für die
partei zu arbeiten dann sind machen sie
sich wieder vom acker friedrich merz
meint nicht nur angela merkel erzielt
auch auf eine andere verklausulierter
annegret kramp karrenbauer ist nicht die
einzige die hier im mittelpunkt der
kritik zu stehen hat sondern es gibt
auch andere und das gesamte
erscheinungsbild der deutschen
bundesregierung ist einfach
grottenschlecht
das alles sagt etwas über friedrich merz
und über die cdu an sich die antwortet
heute nämlich mit gesammeltem schweigen
das zeigt der generalsekretär paul
signac auch julia klöckner
thomas strobl ja alle stellvertretenden
parteivorsitzenden auch die mit
ministerpräsidenten macht volker
bouffier und armin laschet auch ihre
kollegen aus dem osten michael
kretschmer und reiner haseloff
der ein oder andere will die debatte
nicht anheizen mancher findet die kritik
auch richtig gibt sich aber taktisch
uneindeutige wir haben zu viele themen
die seit zehn seit 20 jahren immer
wieder diskutiert werden wurde aber
nicht wirklich einen unterschied gemacht
wird was entschieden wird
und so ist es noch horst seehofer der
als einer von ganz wenigen merkel in
schutz nimmt ausgerechnet ich teile die
kritik von friedrich merz nicht aber
noch lange politische erfahrung weiß ich
dass in einer solchen lage disziplin die
beste eigenschaft ist so ändern sich die
zeiten und die menschen sich mit ihnen
oder eben auch nicht
[Musik]
anja günther ist uns zugeschaltet
ministerpräsident von schleswig holstein
und mitglied im präsidium der cdu guten
abend herr günther neues logo die junge
union erstellt die parteichefin in frage
herr märz stellt die kanzlerin in frage
was ist denn da los in der cdu ist das
der beginn einer grund wollte nein das
glaube ich nicht
ich glaube das ist ein bisschen der
falsche zeitpunkt solche debatten
überhaupt zu führen denn wir haben ja
keine ungeklärten führungsfragen sondern
wir haben eine parteivorsitzende die
gewählt ist wir haben die
bundeskanzlerin und von daher sehe ich
das eigentlich relativ gelassen
aber ich habe schon ein bisschen déjà vu
wenn ich mir angucke wie es mit der spd
angefangen hat wie sie in den umfragen
immer weiter runter gegangen ist genauso
in dem sie sich mit sich selbst
beschäftigt indem sie erfolge der
vergangenheit klein und teilweise
schlecht redet genau das versuchen im
moment einige von der seitenlinie aus
unsere kanzlerin angela merkel hat vier
bundestagswahlen erfolgreich für die
union beschrittene bestritten und von
daher ist meine herzliche bitte an alle
diese sperrfeuer einzustellen und
denjenigen die verantwortung zu
überlassen die im moment gewählt sind
sagt friedrich merz ist kann so nicht
weitergehen und bezieht sich darauf die
wahlergebnisse ich jetzt das debakel in
thüringen aber vorher in sachsen
brandenburg oder bei der europawahl lief
es ja auch nicht besser
hat er da nicht ein punkt zu sagen
wir sind ja auf einer abschüssigen rampe
und da muss was geschehen mehr aber ich
glaube dass die zeit wo man einfach mit
standardfloskeln wahlergebnisse
kommentiert hat einfach vorbei sind was
trifft es uns zu sagen so kann es nicht
weitergehen
das bestreitet ja keiner wenn man eine
landtagswahl wie in thüringen bestreitet
wo die union nur drittstärkste kraft
wird da gibt es keinen der sagt es war
jetzt ja alles richtig gelaufen und
jetzt haben wir halt so ein ergebnis
sondern natürlich müssen wir besser
werden müssen wir auch besser
kommunizieren aber müssen wir eben auch
ein bisschen stärker
wie der politische inhalte nach draußen
kehren wo die menschen sagen dafür trägt
die union verantwortung dafür arbeiten
wir gut und ohne zweifel ist thüringen
ohne bund nicht denkbar ein so
schlechtes ergebnis sondern die
performance der bundesregierung hat ihr
übriges dazu beigetragen aber genau das
ist ja auch eben nicht mit solchen er
sagt ja untätigkeit der kanzlerin als er
argumentiert ja durchaus inhaltlich naja
inhaltlicher nicht sondern er sagte es
darf so nicht weitergehen
und es ist doch ohne zweifel so dass die
bundesregierung im moment kein gutes
image bei der bevölkerung hat aber es
kann uns doch auch nicht wundern wenn
die politischen parteien die in der
bundesregierung tragen
über ihre eigene arbeit schlecht reden
in zweifel ziehen ob eine
bundesregierung überhaupt weiter regiert
wir können noch von den menschen auf der
straße nicht erwarten dass sie unsere
arbeit gut finden wenn wir sie jetzt
nicht gut finden wenn wir uns selbst zur
disposition stellen
und wenn union und spd nicht endlich
lernen dass wenn man politische
verantwortung trägt man diese
verantwortung auch positiv nach draußen
bahn im bus muss sich um die
herausforderungen der menschen zu wird
sich wirklich kümmern muss wenn wir das
nicht gemeinsam lernen
dann werden union und spd insgesamt aus
diesem strudel dich raus kommt darum
müssen wir uns kümmern und das ist die
aufgabe die wir auch als union haben nun
schauen wir uns das aber mal strategisch
an also warum sagt herr merz dass es
kann so zu zwei jahre lang so nicht
weitergehen offenkundig will er ja dass
die kanzlerschaft von angela merkel
vorzeitig endet und möglicherweise
selbst als kanzlerkandidat ins rennen
gehen und es gibt ja einige in der union
die das sehr begrüßen würden
hat er eine chance nein ich glaube das
ist eine debatte die im moment gerade
von älteren männern geführt wird die
vielleicht nicht ihre karriere ziele
erreicht haben in ihrem leben aber das
ist eine sache die sollten sie mit sich
persönlich ausmachen und das sollten sie
jetzt nicht in die cdu eintragen
wir haben die jetzt politische
verantwortung haben wir haben ein ganz
klares zeitzer tableau das bedeutet dass
wir die kanzlerschaft entscheiden im
dezember 2020 und dieser zeitplan wird
von ernstzunehmenden leuten in der union
auch gar nicht bestritten
naja die junge union gehört jetzt nicht
unbedingt zu den älteren zwar auch zu
älteren männern vielfach aber herr kober
nicht einer der sich jetzt ein ganzes
leben an frau merkel ab arbeitet ja aber
trotz alledem fühlt die euro für die
junge union im moment nicht debatte die
genau das gleiche nachvollzieht was die
spd in den abgrund im moment auch treibt
nur personaldebatten urwahlen die eine
partei offenkundig nicht attraktiv
machen
das sind alles debatten die helfen der
union überhaupt nicht weiter und ich
glaube wir sollten uns nicht an der spd
im moment orientieren sondern wir
sollten wieder zu stärke zurückgewinnen
und die menschen wollen von uns
führungsstärke die wollen von uns dass
die probleme diskutiert diskutiert und
auch gelöst werden dass wir in
politischen entscheidungen schneller
werden die menschen dürstet nicht danach
dass parteien sich noch viel aufwendiger
mit personal beschäftigen
der wirft von daher wünsche ich mir
ausdrücklich auch von der jungen union
eher eine stärkung der politischen
führung als eine schwächung sagt anja
günther ministerpräsident von
schleswig-holstein dank für das
interview sehr gerne das interview haben
wir am frühen abend geführt
in hongkong kämpfen die
regierungskritiker noch um den letzten
rest demokratischer freiheiten der ihnen
geblieben ist seitdem china das ruder
übernommen hat
wie begrenzt diese freiräume schon sinn
zeigt sich aktuell auch daran dass der
prominente bürgerrechtler joshua bonn
heute von der kandidatur bei der
anstehenden kommunalwahl ausgeschlossen
wurde dass er als einziger bewerber
nicht zugelassen wurde wertet worden als
eine klar politisch motivierte
entscheidung
immerhin kann er das noch öffentlich
sagen in festland china würde er kaum
noch ein medium finden dass sie
überhaupt gehör verschafft chinas
internet ist umfänglich zensiert die
presse auf linie und nun wird für
journalisten auch noch ein
gesinnungstest eingeführt ganz modern
per app doch im geiste sind es die alten
maut seiten in die die volksrepublik
zurückkehrt ulf röller berichtet china
hat schon einmal brutal die gesinnung
seiner bürger getestet während der
kulturrevolution die mao bibel mit den
weisheiten des großen vorsitzenden
verkündete die absolute wahrheit
shipping auch präsident auf lebenszeit
wandelt auf mautspuren mit seiner app
villa die loyalität der journalisten
testen dort zu finden die gedankenwelt
des heutigen großen vorsitzenden
die journalisten müssen sie auswendig
lernt er den test nicht besteht verliert
seinen job
ich übe jeden tag mit der app nicht nur
jetzt wegen der prüfung aber die sorgt
dafür dass sich die app noch öfter
benutze 100 fragen mindestens 80 muss
man wissen um zu bestehen
kostprobe was verlangt präsident von
politischen kadern wissen oder loyalität
zur partei
loyalität ist richtig in diesem sinne
sind pressekonferenzen in china gut
inszenierte show veranstaltungen fragen
und antworten fein abgestimmt
nein ich darf zum test nicht sagen er
will sein gesicht nicht zeigen seinen
namen nicht nennen er muss auf seine
worte aufpassen
kritik am staat ist gefährlich er ist
journalist einer von tausenden in peking
ich habe keine wahl wenn ich diese
prüfung nicht mache bekomme ich keinen
journalisten ausweis das heißt ich kann
meinen beruf nicht ausüben
präsident skis lehrsätze zu der aufgabe
der medien muss er jetzt büffelt einer
lautet positive propaganda sei wichtiger
als sich streng an die wahrheit zu
halten
vor allem muss ich wissen wie sie die
rolle der medien sieht sie haben der
partei zu dealen feiern lässt er sich
beim besuch des staatsfernsehens was er
denkt und sagt ist gesetz
wer kritisch berichtet dem drohen
strafen 150 journalisten sitzen derzeit
im gefängnis
wir erleben im moment eine unfassbare
welle der repression und gleichschaltung
wie sie vorher so doch auch nicht
denkbar war der loyalität test knüpft an
dunkle seiten der chinesischen
geschichte an
seit skis machtübernahme schreitet die
gleichschaltung der medien voran
ich vermisse wie es früher war damals
die journalisten mehr freiheiten es gab
kritische berichte die medien haben nur
noch eine propaganda rolle
nach präsident ist der gesinnungstest
keine zensur die gleichschaltung der
journalisten nennt er loyalität
[Musik]
in sachen rexit gibt es wieder einmal
eine neue wendung kann ja nach dem
fehlversuch gestern hat es der britische
premierminister boris johnson heute
geschafft das unterhaus stimmte für
vorgezogene neuwahlen und zwar am 12
dezember johnson bekam heute auch die
unterstützung der oppositionellen labour
partei für den neuen vorschlag
er will damit einen ausweg aus dem
festgefahrenen streit über das brett
abkommen mit der eu erreichen
im moment ist vorgesehen dass
großbritannien die gemeinschaft bis zum
31 januar verlässt die bedrohung durch
rechtsextremismus in deutschland ist
nach einschätzung des
verfassungsschutzes in den vergangenen
zwölf monaten deutlich größer geworden
bei einer anhörung im bundestag sagte
verfassungsschutzpräsident halten wann
eine neue bedrohung gehe unter anderem
von einem virtuellen rechtsextremismus
aus der in der digitalen welt entstehe
und sich auch in die realität fortsetze
messenger dienste und gruppen machten es
möglich hassbotschaften schnell und
umfassend zu verbreiten
außerdem sind halten bank deutschland
weiter im visier islamistischer
terroristen
in der ost ukraine gibt es nach
jahrelangen kämpfen neue zeichen der
entspannung sowohl die ukrainische armee
als auch die prorussischen separatisten
haben in einer weiteren region begonnen
ihre truppen einen kilometer von der
frontlinie zurückzuziehen
der abzug ist eine der bedingungen
russlands für ein erstes treffen
zwischen den präsidenten putin und sie
lenski in nordsyrien im grenzgebiet zur
türkei endete am nachmittag offiziell
die vereinbarte waffenruhe
nach angaben des russischen
verteidigungsministers ist die
kurdenpolitik eg bereits vor ablauf der
frist abgezogen
die türkei teilte daraufhin mit sie
wolle das mit patrouillen überprüfen
es gibt allerdings auch berichte über
vereinzelte kämpfe zwischen der
türkischen armee und ihren lokalen
verbündeten mit der syrischen
regierungstruppen auf beiden seiten soll
es tote gegeben haben
libanons ministerpräsident saad hariri
hat seinen rücktritt angekündigt der
reagiert damit auf die seit fast zwei
wochen anhaltenden proteste gegen
korruption und misswirtschaft im land in
einer fernsehansprache sagte hariri dass
er eine sackgasse erreicht habe auch
jüngste zugeständnisse der regierung
konnten die proteste nicht eindämmen
die demonstranten feierten den rücktritt
gleichzeitig wiederholten sie ihre
forderungen nach einer erneuerung des
politischen systems
die chance gesund zu leben zumindest in
einer umwelt die an das ermöglicht auch
das ist ein menschenrecht
das war eine der zentralen aussagen beim
weltgesundheitsgipfel in berlin experten
aus über 100 ländern nahmen daran teil
besonders interessant waren jene
themenbereiche die tatsächlich global
sind die also auch menschen überall auf
der welt betreffen allen voran der
klimawandel zu dessen folgen eben auch
spezifische gesundheitsprobleme gehören
hitzewellen zum beispiel auf die wir
zumindest in unseren breitengraden noch
nicht wirklich eingestellt sind
christian kirsch berichtet
klimaschutz ist gesundheitsschutz sagt
drk lewski hausarzt in gummersbach
zuständig für tausende patienten stellt
er fest die spürbare veränderung des
klimas macht krank vor allem hitzewellen
mit temperaturen tage lang über 40 grad
treiben die menschen zum arzt die
probleme erschöpfung und
konzentrationsstörungen kopfschmerzen
auch das gefühl einer deutliche
leistungsminderung wenn sie dann 8
stunden durcharbeiten müssen auch mit
geringen pausen in rom stressbelastung
dann kommen leute zu ihrem haus als name
ich kann nicht mehr
dann schreiben wir die krankheiten gibt
es der erschöpfung es leiden vor allem
ältere patienten seit drei jahren genau
leide ich unter herz kreislauf
beschwerden bis hin zu schwerer atemnot
bei temperaturen von 40 grad denn hitze
macht krank der arbeits und
lebensrhythmus der deutschen ist nicht
angepasst und solche temperaturen
statistiken belegen hitze tötet auch im
sommer 2008 zehn starben in hessen 740
menschen mehr als statistisch erwartbar
wäre in berlin 490 im heißen sommer 2003
so französische forscher sterben in
europa etwa 70.000 menschen mehr als
sonst üblich universität heidelberg am
institut für globale gesundheit werden
die vielfältigen einflüsse des
klimawandels auf die gesundheit
erforscht weltweit so das resultat
leidet der mensch egal ob das jetzt die
direkten gesundheitsprobleme sind durch
hitze auf unser atem system auf unser
kardiovaskuläres also kreislauf system
oder aber eben die indirekten folgen
durch verschlechterung der
landwirtschaftlichen produktion durch
migration kann man das auf jeden fall
mehr jahren dass der klimawandel ein
gesundheitliches problem ist klimawandel
ursache für gesundheitsschäden auf
vielen ebenen die tigermücke etwa liebt
die wärme und breitet sich immer weiter
richtung norden aus sie überträgt
krankheiten wie das berüchtigte denken
auch allergien verstärkt der klimawandel
allergieauslöser wie etwa polen treten
bei zunehmender wärmen nicht nur länger
auf sie werden bei höherer co2
konzentration auch aggressiver auch die
luftverschmutzung steigt denn beim eher
stabilen wetterlagen sorgt geringerer
luftaustausch des moc das verursachte
erkrankungen der atemwege wie etwa
asthma dr koletzki stellt fest
deutschlands medizin unterschätzt das
problem das ganze hat das deutsche
gesundheitswesen bislang noch nicht
umfangreich genug erreicht aber die
deutsche ärzteschaft hat jetzt beim
ärztetag in münster im mai dieses jahres
beschlossen das ist ein schwerpunktthema
in 20 20 zu machen das problem sagt der
haus wird eher grösser werden
auf dem weg zum hausbesuch kein auto er
nimmt immer das rad klimaschutz im
kleinen
und jetzt nochmal andere nachricht des
tages von hans wolff wirtschaftsminister
altmaier ist heute beim digital gipfel
der bundesregierung in dortmund nach
seiner rede beim verlassen der bühne
gestürzt
er wurde ins krankenhaus gebracht hat
aber inzwischen bereits per
kurznachricht wissen lassen außer
prellungen und platzwunden sei offenbar
nichts ernstes den wirtschaftsminister
ging es bei diesen digital gipfel um ein
großes projekt ein europäisches cloud
netzwerk frank bethmann
was kann man sich darunter vorstellen
was ist da geplant naja moderne
unternehmen produzieren heute immer mehr
daten und diese daten werden inzwischen
zur besseren verfügbarkeit in sogenannte
cloud ausgelagert das problem ursächlich
für die heutige initiative ist dass die
meisten dieser ausgelagerten daten auf
server banken us-amerikanischer konzerne
liegen
amazon microsoft und google dominieren
die cloud dienste und haben analysen
zufolge einen weltweiten marktanteil von
fast 75 prozent
auch riesige datenmengen deutscher
konzerne und behörden werden dort
gespeichert wissen muss man in diesem
zusammenhang dass daten als der rohstoff
der zukunft gelten dass daten in
verbindung mit künstlicher intelligenz
künftig über erfolg und misserfolg
entscheiden werden in europa fürchten
deshalb politik und industrie in einer
amerikanische abhängigkeit zu geraten
und an souveränität zu verlieren
so gesehen ist das heute auf dem digital
gipfel vorgestellte projekt garics der
versuch eine eigene europäische daten
infrastruktur aufzubauen
eben ein europäisches cloud netzwerk mit
an bord sind auch mehrere dax konzerne
wie sap die telekom die deutsche bank
und siemens
der vorstoss geht in die richtige
richtung doch sind die amerikaner der
europäischen wirtschaft in diesen
punkten meilenweit voraus die us tech
giganten stecken jährlich milliarden in
den ausbau ihrer cloud dienste
es ist also mehr als fraglich ob die
europäische initiative diesen rückstand
aufholen kann
frank bethmann vielen dank fast ein
drittel aller eltern in deutschland
lesen ihren kindern im alter zwischen
zwei und acht jahren selten oder nie vor
zu diesem ergebnis kommt die aktuelle
vorlese studie die heute in berlin
vorgestellt wurde
der hauptgeschäftsführer der stiftung
lesen maas betonte wie wichtig das
vorlesen für die bildung und die
entwicklung der kinder ist weiter zum
fußball und ergebnissen aus der zweiten
runde des dfb pokals die heute abend
begonnen hat regionalligist saarbrücken
gewinnt 3 2 gegen den bundesligisten
erst der fc köln weitere ergebnisse
hamburger sv vfb stuttgart 1 2 nach
verlängerung duisburg hoffenheim 0 2 sc
freiburg und berlin 1 zu 3 vfl buchung
bayern münchen 1 zu 2 der nepalese in
jamaal porsche hat einen rekord im
bergsteigen aufgestellt und zwar für die
schnellste besteigung aller 14
achttausender der 36-jährige kletterer
brauchte dafür 189 tage
der bisherige rekord lag bei fast acht
jahren
als letzten berg besteht forscher den
8027 meter hohen shisha pangma in china
mit seiner aktion wolle er die
nepalesischen kletterer ermuntern nicht
nur als helfer in expeditionen zu
arbeiten als erster bergsteiger hatte
reinhold messner 1986 alle achttausender
geschafft messen gratulierte bürger nun
für seine einzigartige leistung alte
bauwerke können neueste high tech
durchaus in den schatten stellen
ein beispiel neben der silhouette des
kölner doms sieht die große neue
hoffnungsträgerin der europäischen
raumfahrt im maßstab ziemlich klein aus
trotz ihrer höhe von 60 metern
aber wie rakete hat es in sich
startbereit ist sie schwerer als sein
voll besetzte a380 großraumjets die
ariane-rakete nummer sechs ist quasi das
neue wunderding die unbemannte
trägerrakete soll mehr leistung bringen
die kosten für einen start ins all aber
fast halbiert sein und flexibler als
bisher statt zwei können auch vier
antriebs booster montiert werden um
gleich zwei tonnen schweren satelliten
auf einmal nach oben befördern zu können
die konkurrenz auf dem markt der als
spediteure ist härter geworden
nächstes jahr soll es mit der ariane 6
schon losgehen und daran gebaut wird
unter anderem in bremen wo heute ein
ariane zentrum feierlich eröffnet wurde
keine class berichtet
diesen countdown der ariane 6 fiebern
die ingenieure schon jetzt entgegen ob
die neue rakete eine ähnlich
erfolgreiche zukunft haben wird wie ihr
vorgängermodell
sie soll nach konzernangaben 40 prozent
billiger werden als die aktuelle
trägerrakete ariane 5
einer der ingenieure max reinhardt ist
für den zusammenbau im reinraum
zuständig der vor dreck und
luftfeuchtigkeit besonders geschützt ist
in der automobilindustrie kennen sie das
schon lange ich habe also eine gewisse
taktzeit pro fertigungs station und
liefert dann eben in der
automobilindustrie pro stunde ein auto
aus bei uns ist diese stunde einen monat
und wir liefern dann hoffentlich jeden
monat eine neue oberstufe aus doch noch
fehlen einige aufträge für so eine
fließbandproduktion heute wurde zwar der
staat dafür gegeben doch es gibt erst
acht aufträge für die raumfahrt
missionen der ariane 6
grund für die schleppende bestellen
laune ist die harte konkurrenz
und offenbar eine wettbewerbsverzerrung
in den usa und china die usa erwähnt
es gibt da an bei amerika markt wo die
institutionellen satelliten können
ausschließlich mit einer amerikanischen
rakete gestartet werden wir wissen dass
eine falcon 9 rakete beispielsweise für
institutionellen lounges für 100
millionen dollar angeboten wird und wir
wissen auch dass im kommerziellen markt
die gleiche rakete wird für 50 millionen
dollar angeboten das heißt nasa oder
us-verteidigungsministerium zahlen
doppelt so viel wie etwa private
auftraggeber für ein raketen transport
der spacex und subventionieren somit den
preis für die konkurrenz rakete der
ariane 6
und auch ariane zulieferer wie ohg
reagieren auf den sich verändernden
markt die satellitenhersteller aus
bremen wollen bereits ende nächsten
jahres eine eigene rakete zünden wir
sind mehr raum firma und der zugang zum
weltraum ist ein ganz ganz wesentlicher
teil
insofern wollen wir da auch mitspielen
und es ist auch spannend zu sehen wie so
eine kleine rakete jetzt entsteht diese
schöne übersichtliche welt das ist in
europa die organe gab dann gab es noch
die russen dann gab es noch wenige
amerikaner die
mitgemacht haben die hat sich jetzt
natürlich grundlegend verändert so will
habe offenbar mindestens 80 mitarbeiter
aus der ariane 6 produktion abziehen ist
die neue rakete also bereits ein
auslaufmodell
es wird auch in zukunft der bedarf
bestehen schwere nutzlasten in den orbit
zu bringen für wissenschafts satelliten
also gerade das was die leser auch
hauptsächlich macht mit ihren
wissenschaftsrat litten dafür brauchen
wir große lounge bei ariane 6 hoffmann
daher dass ein geglückter start im
nächsten jahr die beste eigenwerbung
sein wird das war's im heute journal
weiter geht es mit der reportage reihe
37° heute mit der eher seltenen
gelegenheit einer staatsanwältin hautnah
bei der arbeit zuzusehen
die in der realität ein bisschen anders
ist ein kredit und um 00 45 gibt es dann
heute plus mit daniel backhaus bis
morgen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten liebe zuschauer morgen los ist
meist wieder sonnig und der regen an den
alpen lässt auch endlich wieder nach
ja wir haben ja einen hohen luftdruck
der steigt auch noch ein bisschen in
deutschland das hoch bekommt
gesellschaft von einem neuen hoch von
der nordsee her und das sorgt für viel
sonnenschein allerdings an den alpen
ziehen eben immer noch die regengebiete
nach osten und damit ist wahrscheinlich
erst morgen nachmittag am späten
nachmittag wirklich schluss dann lässt
der regen nach ja heute nacht haben
diesen regen noch vor allen dingen an
den alpen und das bedeutet vor allen
dingen der zweiten nachthälfte ist auch
ein bisschen stärker nach norden hin in
der mitte deutschlands mittelgebirge da
haben nebelfelder und im norden wird es
klar
die luft ist trocken und es wird sehr
kalt frost bekommen wir null bis minus
fünf grad während es unter den
regenwolken hier ganz im süden
doch ziemlich mild bleibt tagsüber
ändern sich die temperaturen kaum
gegenüber heute im regen sind das fünf
grad an den alpen auch in den
mittelgebirgen etwa sonst aber wieder
acht bis elf grad und in norddeutschland
scheint dann auch meist die sonne vor
allem hier an den küsten ist der himmel
oft wolkenlos sonst haben wir so
hochnebel und nebel vom harz bis zum
erzgebirge das dauert bis der sich
tatsächlich aufgelöst hat nach süden hin
wechseln sonne und wolken etwa bis zur
donau
dann ist es wieder stark bewölkt oder
ziehen die wolken noch durch mit dem
regen aber am späten nachmittag ist wo
der regen vorbei auch an den alpen unter
wind weht schwach aus osten die
aussichten der donnerstag wird trocken
teilweise ein bisschen wolkig noch im
süden aber da regnet es nicht mehr dann
am freitag ändert sich die wetterlage
der wind dreht und von westen kommt
regen auf und das wochenende für zwar
milder aber auch nasser ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und nachts